this big story this morning outgoing FDA
Commissioner Scott Gottlieb says the
agency could move to ban e cigarette
pods to stop teenagers from using them
in his only network television interview
during his final week in office he told
our own dr. Jon LaPook the companies
that make east cigarettes must do more
to prevent minors from getting hold of
them
it is estimated that more than 3.6
million middle and high school students
vaped last year among high school
students there was a 78 percent increase
in vaping from 2017 you know this is a
major concern this happened in the last
two years this is something that caught
everyone by surprise if we see another
sharp increase in the youth rates this
year we're gonna have to look at more
draconian measures like potentially
taking these pod based products off the
market entirely have you had any
pushback from the administration about
your proposals the issues around the
youth use of the e-cigarettes have broad
support I don't think anyone in this
administration certainly no one I've
encountered wants to see a generation of
kids become addicted to nicotine three
cigarettes if these rates continue to go
up and they don't start to come down
though the entire marketability of this
category of products is going to be
called into question these pod based
cigarette products like jewel like jewel
exactly jewel CEO Kevin burns says the
company has taken action to prevent use
by minors including restricting the
sales of flavored pods and shutting down
its Facebook and Instagram accounts
Jewell also says it supports banning kid
appealing flavors and raising the
minimum age for buying vaping products
to 21 nationwide Commissioner Gottlieb's
last day at the FDA is Friday dr. Jon
LaPook
is here good morning John why is he
leaving first of all he says that you
know he's got three young daughters at
home and he hates the commute he wants
to see them growing up that's that's
what his excuse and what could the FBI
do to read to get to lower vaping
because the kids I know get around and
they get around any blocks that you put
in from yeah that's the question is you
know what can you do because even if
Jill is saying we're taking steps on
social media and we're gonna make it
less available to have these flavored
pods but the best marketers are the kids
themselves and they're in junior high
it's very easy they kind of you know
look very very easy to use without
anybody sort of seeing them so the
question is what can be done that's why
he's saying we may be taking draconian
measures well some of the things that
help with actual smoking cigarettes was
a was an education campaign after of
course the Attorney General's sued the
tobacco industry what do we know are the
health effects of these cigarettes
specifically on the brain right and the
question is on the developing brain you
can get addicted to nicotine so yes
there is a role probably for people who
are already smoking to help them get off
of cigarettes but what about the person
the kid who's never smoked at all has
never used any nicotine now it's kind of
cool to use and you get addicted and
then there is some evidence that if
you've never used cigarettes before and
you start off with these e-cigarettes
you might have an increased risk of
going on to smoking cigarettes later
well not in the same way that the tar
causes with cigarettes there are some
substances in the e-cigarettes that may
we not sure what the effects are but
certainly not that the same effect but
they they're addictive and who wants a
generation of kids addicted and and then
there may be other changes in the brain
this research going on right now about
other changes in the brain that can be
happening I mean this is a
pharmacologically very active substance
yeah but is it a better alternative to
the traditional cigarettes because we
know that those are bad yeah there's no
doubt the regular so you have to do it
if you are smoking already and it's
helping you to get off it it's an
off-ramp great the question is if you've
never smoked you've got these teenagers
and you're suddenly addicting them
because it's cool and I know you talked
to doctor got League also about the
growing number of states that are
allowing the recreational use of
marijuana what did the doctor say well
you know he is concerned also about the
the effect of marijuana on the
developing brain - and there is some
evidence about that and I asked him
about you know isn't it time for it to
no longer be a Schedule one on the same
level as heroin because it's made it so
hard to do research on it and kind of
shame on us it's been around for all
these thousands of years and certainly
in the last 50 years we haven't done
enough research he said yeah he favors
being able to have more research but of
course it's under the control of the DEA
in terms of making a ruling like that
so talking to you it sounds like he's
ready to go do you know what he plans to
do next well and he gave me a little
clue I'm not sure he meant to but he's
talking about drug crisis and about
trying to control them and I said
you have all these ideas he has his arms
around all these facts why don't you
just stay here and fix the drug crisis
he says well I can do that from the
outside I said really how are you gonna
do that he said stay tuned well I know
from both hearing from you and dr. agus
that he was one of the toughest FDA
commissioners and really bringing this
to light very aggressive agenda and it's
surprising and well liked and well liked
yeah thank you John thank you